ja einen wunderschönen guten Tag Ina ich
habe eine Frage oder ich muss D vorher
lieber erst einmal vorwarnen und zwar
vor dem Moderator vor Christoph und zwar
ist der so ein bisschen skeptisch was
die Nordlichter angeht ich habe das
selber schon am eigenen Leibe erfahren
und wir müssen jetzt beide mal versuchen
ih so ein bisschen zu überzeugen von dem
hohen Norden von dem Meer und wie schön
es hier doch eigentlich ist und ich gehe
einfach mal davon aus dass du es ja auch
sehr schön findest deswegen ist meine
Frage auch liebe Ina warum gefällt dir
der Norden so gut warum gefällt dir das
Meer so gut warum gefällt dir das flache
Land so gut ich gehe einfach mal davon
aus dass es so ist das ist meine Frage
und danke schön für die Antwort tschüss
t alle Säule natürlich gefällt mir der
Norden gut ich habe aber auch sechs
Jahre lang schon im Süden gelebt ich
würde gerne wissen guck ich dich an nein
son oder gucke ich einfach Torge ich
habe aber auch se Jahre schon im Süden
gelebt und mir gefallen die Berge auch
sehr gut ich bin aber natürlich im
Norden sehr verwurzelt ich bin mit
meinem plattdeutschen sehr verwurzelt
wir Nordlichter wir sind irgendwie
bohstänig und wir waren immer schon am
Tor zur weiten Welt zu Hause ich weiß es
nicht warum muss ich Christoph überreden
Norddeutschland gut zu finden ich glaube
wenn Norddeutschland nicht gut findet
hat eben Problem auch noch in auf
anderen Ebenen sexuell wahrscheinlich na
danke